i don't name stuff i have many facets of
weird
and i admit that but naming like
inanimate objects is not one of it but i
don't mind people who do i don't mind at
all
what's up gq i'm jacob montgomery and
these are my 10 essentials
[Music]
so for me my first essential is my
lighting i'm super weird
about my space i'm really ocd about the
house and i love my space i think space
is all about light
you can buy these smart lighting
packages called hue h-u-e
light bulbs basically you connect this
box to your wi-fi router and that box
creates a little wi-fi network for all
of the light bulbs
in your house when we moved into our new
place i started building a lighting
scape that was like predominantly
these light sort of purpley hues and
everything's on the floor and shines up
i hate down lights i'm really weird
about down lights and i never use them
so in our living room we've got a couple
and in our bedroom we also have a couple
and then i have one in my office behind
this marble slab that just sort of kind
of
illuminates the edging i'm super like
sensitive about it when i sort of go to
bed i slowly bring the whole light in
the house down
over half an hour when i'm getting ready
for bed i'm really interested in life
i'm really interested in how it can
completely change a mood and a space
but it's really important for me to
build a lighting scape in my space
that's a big thing when i travel which
is probably my segue into the second
essential i don't have smart lighting so
i have to use
candles again it's that whole down light
thing i don't like to have down lights
so we buy candles when we're away
whether they're just your normal white
candles or they're you know
something like this more of a designer
candle with like a really nice scent in
it this is
balinese ylang ylang
this is a popular brand in australia
super nice smells fantastic
but yeah so candles when we're away i
sort of are a heavy supplement but when
we're here as you'll see we've got like
candelabras all through the house
and i go through a ton of tea lights and
a ton of small candles and we just it's
kind of it when i'm having a shower at
night and
i'm getting ready for bed we have this
little marble slab that sits in our
bathroom and i just like one candle in
there it's all about lighting
when i grew up my mum used to move the
house around like every two weeks she'd
move all the furniture around
sometimes buy new things change things
up and every night it was my job to set
the table the dining table was the
center of our house it was
where we all came at the end of a long
day and we all spoke about our day and
shared experiences
so like from a very young age it was
instilled in me that
that i didn't have to by any means but i
somehow had like this profound
engagement and interest in
in light and design and home the idea of
home became so important to me
it's just mainly around dinner time and
after dinner if you're watching tv
that's like the most important time for
me to
set the mood with candles and i
literally cannot focus on a movie
like i'm so particular about my
peripherals like when i go to the cinema
i have to sit
for a second or third row and have
nothing in my peripherals because i feel
like
a movie should be or television should
be a completely immersive experience
and then so when i'm at home i feel
obviously very ocd about
my environment right so if i'm sitting
and watching a movie last night we
watched jackie brown for the first time
and just everything kind of in my
periphery has to match the film
and if that candle's out of place i'm
gonna pause the film and i'm gonna get
up and
shift it you know until it's in the
right place so it's also
heavily tied to filming television and
and dinner
those two sort of entertaining
experiences
the third thing in conjunction i guess
with lighting but again a good segue
into another essential
my car i love cars and i always do a ton
of research before i buy a car
and so i i went and bought a mercedes
e220d
it's one of those beautiful ones that
you sometimes see on tv shows with
the screen right across the dash and all
of the lighting built in and
sound is so important to me as well
fantastic audio system
and the preset of the lighting all the
way through the car is the exact same
purple hue as
my whole house like from the outside
it's kind of just a white
mercedes sedan but on the inside it's
all immersive as i say between this
screen which really attracted me the
lighting component and then the sound
component and you know when i was lucky
enough to be able to afford it
you know it was the first thing i went
out and did i don't name stuff
i'm not that that's not i have many
facets of weird
and i admit that but naming like
inanimate objects it's not one of it but
i don't mind people who do
i don't mind at all but i just got roof
racks for it which has changed the game
because i wanted to be able to put my
surfboard which is probably another good
segue
so this surfboard
you can see it it's super cool this is
not the surfboard that i
ride i have a different one down in our
shed next to our car
but basically this board was given to me
by an australian
he had a friend who is a photographer
who takes these shots of
you know the ocean good surroundings and
this is some beautiful
uh sort of foam off the ocean heading
towards the shore and then this is like
that beautiful
dark color the ocean can get so i love
it so it actually
exists as an art piece in our house i
have not been surfing for long at all
i've only been surfing for about
a year and a quarter my partner grew up
surfing
she's a phenomenal surfer and i have
lots of mates that surf
i have a big connection to the ocean i
grew up free diving
was part of my high school curriculum
you could opt to do
it as a program so i kind of fell in
love with the ocean when i was really
little
and then sort of through my adolescence
i had the opportunity
on multiple occasions to sort of become
a freediver that was my thing
so surfing is just another way to have
an excuse to go every day
basically the surfboard that i actually
use is an epoxy board
it's quite wide and it's about 36 liters
which is quite buoyant
because i'm a chunky chunky guy
so i like to have a more buoyant board i
quit coffee like two and a half years
ago
because i was getting the shakes and i
was just drinking way too much so i took
up drinking tea
every morning instead just regular old
english breakfast or
black tea every morning i get up and i
have a cup of tea
out of this teapot at the moment when
we're home which is like a nice little
glass
tea pot from t2 it was a gift um from
my dad and his partner every night i go
to bed
i brew this tea and i put it in the
fridge
and i get it really nice and cold and
then in the morning
i get up and i pour it in this cup with
a dash of milk and it's kind of my
thing i have like an iced unsweetened
tea i guess every morning so i can't
drink anything
warm i hate hot drinks they just give me
like
i don't know the heebie-jeebies like i
don't i'm not really into it
so when i was little my parents and i
went to japan and we went to this
amazing
pottery warehouse in tokyo full of these
beautiful handmade japanese plates
bowls and cutlery and all kinds of just
amazing things and we bought a bunch of
it back these beautiful gray handmade
bowls they've got like this amazing
sort of rough texture on the outside and
then on the inside they're usually
heavily glossed
and they have amazing patterns and
prints and all kinds of stuff that's all
hand painted
underneath when i eventually kind of
moved permanently
out of home it was really important to
me to have
plates bowls and stuff like that so we
managed to get a whole bunch of japanese
bowls
and basically what i mean by that is
something like this which you can see it
says
made in japan and basically they just
have amazing texture
they're really nice to touch everything
looks amazing so when we serve food it
looks pretty incredible
something like this as i say which has
sort of a rougher exterior and then it's
super polished inside
and you can see all this cracked um
turquoise
glass right in the middle there which is
just amazing i don't know i've just it's
always been a big thing and we have
obviously matching sets of
bowls and plates and little bowls and
side plates and stuff that are all this
kind of um
milky color like this piece of marble
here like all the wood in our house
matches our bowls it's all this beige
light colored wood
a lot of time and attention to detail
and like it pays off because you just
feel super comfortable in your own
environment
my biggest source of productivity
especially as a freelancer is
my laptop because i keep all of my
research information
writings sketchings everything on there
so my desktop is kind of a litter
of just uh tons of different ideas or
projects that i've had or things that
i've been working on
obviously a big part of that is is my
poetry or writings
stuff that i've sort of done on the side
my poetry started out as a bit of a
cathartic experience i would always
write when i was really anxious
and basically just wrote and wrote and
wrote and i've just got
piles of notes and i've just finished my
first book which is basically a book of
poems
so ground up i've worked off my laptop
on that book
so this is my laptop this is a regular
old mac
unfortunately uh again in keeping with
the aesthetic i like that sort of super
sleek space gray
no stickers or anything i'm a bit of a
cheap skate as they say so i actually
don't have any like
paid uh software on my laptop so i just
use pages
and then i also pull up in tandem with
little notes box
so i'm working kind of in one level of
consciousness here which is more like a
stream of consciousness
and then i pull lines that i like out as
i'm going and copy and paste them across
but i'll always have like a spotify bar
running in the bottom right hand corner
to kind of like tandem whatever my mood
is
to help get those notes onto the page
i've only done a couple of projects in
my career but whenever i finish a
project
i have it a bound i have this company in
sydney that helps me do it
basically i just put them all together
like this
this was the first film i ever did power
rangers and
i just pulled a script and i put it
inside the book
no matter what the film becomes and what
the edit looks like this is usually the
wrap
script and then i just put in there
chapter one chapter two
is the stranger things which was the
second project that i worked on
so basically i took i think episode 201
chapter one mad max chapter three which
is
stranger things season three and the
broken art gallery
which is chapter four and then i have
my own script which is the first script
that i wrote was my
short film in vitro which is called
chapter one from a different
category i guess being my own and i had
that found in
sort of black faux leather but i had had
this idea
after power rangers and i think during
stranger things
that i just wanted this memory of
of something so these have been great
and it's not something i look at all the
time but it's definitely nice to have
them
here i also keep memorabilia from
sex which you could say is probably
stolen definitely
so from broken hearts i took nick's
bracelet and then i have a box of stuff
which is full of different things so i
have the denim jacket that i wore
as billy and i have a box of marlboro
red cigarettes because i wanted to smoke
them instead of herbal cigarettes as
billy because the smoke is thicker and
it feels like an honest portrayal
and then when i did power rangers there
was this massive glass wall made of
stuff called obsidian
rock which was like when we discovered
the key to unlock the whole narrative of
the film
there were these coins inside the wall
and on the night they had these massive
cannons blocked by
the glass and grabbed a piece and i
still have it so just it's a little
thing from each
project i always kept stuff when i would
travel as a kid i had a
diary my mum would say you know do you
want to keep a diary and i was terrible
with writing in it i would stick like a
pebble
and i would put the pebble in the diary
and i would go lived in switzerland with
mum for three months
here's the pebble from my time i would
go to canada and i'd get a little piece
of wood
and i would stow it in my thing and make
up a story about it or whatever else
and i went home over the quarantine
break and basically pulled out this box
for the first time in years for these
little things
and you have to really think about it
because now it's just a box of pebbles
and wood
it forces you to use it as a touchstone
and go what was happening in that point
in your life and all that sort of stuff
so
everything is symbolic another big thing
for me and this truly i feel
is an essential is is sound growing up
and still now
my dad was a sound recourse and when i
was little he taught me the value of
sound of picking up and hearing every
single piece of dialogue and
every little taste and texture in
someone's mouth the movement of their
clothes
the scene so when i was little i was
exposed to that and i was exposed to
a stepfather who listened to so much
music and introduced me to
the power of music i guess it was
extremely important to me to have a
really good sound system
in our house so we have all these sonar
speakers all throughout our house
and i love like adjusting them to
different regions of our house like our
lighting
our bedroom has kind of one thing going
on in our kitchen
and our living room and our bathroom and
my office and so on and so forth but the
biggest reason that
audio is so essential to me it's again
part of my routine
every morning i get up and i listen to
the same album and i can't start my day
any other way it's an album by an artist
called nick drake i get up every morning
and i put it on and that's kind of the
way i get through my day and when it
comes to dinner
i have another album that i play while
we're cooking
audio like sound is everything to me we
listen to white noise
when we're sleeping it's like i use it
to ebb and flow
everything in my life is tailored to
sound and noise
you know i know those around me are so
sick of it because i listen to the same
music at the start and mostly at the end
of the day but it really does help me to
get into one zone and it's a really good
way that i've used to sort of channel my
anxiety
and it sort of levels me out every
morning i get up i pull the tee
and that just hits me in and then every
night i turn on my lighting my candles
and then it's like okay i'm in evening
mode thank you everyone for listening
those were my essentials and uh this is
kind of
uh welcome to my crazy weird life of
things